as a boy in Lima my grandfather told me
a legend of the Spanish conquest of Peru
at the Y by emperor of the Inca had been
captured and killed Pizarro and his
conquistadors has grown rich and tales
of their conquest and glory had reached
Spain and was bringing new waves of
Spaniards hungry for gold and glory they
would go into towns and ask the Inca
where's another civilization we could
conquer where's more gold and the Inca
out of vengeance told them go to the
Amazon you'll find all the gold you want
there in fact there is a city called by
didi in Doral in Spanish made entirely
of gold
the Spanish set off into the jungle but
the few that returned come back with
stories stories of powerful shamans of
warriors with poisoned arrows of trees
so tall they blotted out the Sun spiders
that ate birds snakes that swallowed men
whole and a river that boiled all this
became a childhood memory and years past
I'm working on my PhD at SMU trying to
understand Peru's geothermal energy
potential when I remember this legend
and I began asking that question could
the boiling River exist
I asked colleagues from universities the
government oil gas and mining companies
and the answer was well my unanimous no
and this makes sense
you see boiling rivers do exist in the
world but they're generally associated
with volcanoes you need a powerful heat
source to produce such a large
geothermal manifestation and as you can
see from the red dots here which are
volcanoes we don't have volcanoes in the
Amazon
nor in most of Peru so it follows we
should not expect to see a boiling River
telling the same story at a family
dinner my aunt tells me but no one that
is I've been there I've swum in that
river then my uncle jumps in no one this
she's not kidding you see you can only
swim in it after a very heavy rain and
it's protected by a powerful shaman
you're on she's friends with his wife
Gamow you know despite all my scientific
skepticism I found myself hiking into
the jungle guided by my aunt over 700
kilometers away from the nearest
volcanic centre and well honestly
mentally preparing myself to behold the
legendary warm stream of the Amazon but
then I heard something a low surge that
got louder and louder as we came closer
it sounded like ocean waves constantly
crashing and as we got closer I saw
smoke vapor coming up through the trees
and then I saw this I immediately
grabbed for my thermometer in the
temperatures the average temperatures in
the river were 86 degrees C this is not
quite the hundred degrees C boiling but
definitely close enough the river flowed
hot and fast I followed it up River and
was led by actually the shamans
apprentice to the most sacred side on
the river and this is what's bizarre it
starts off as a cold stream and here at
the site is the home of the yaku mama
mother of the waters a giant serpent
spirit who burns hot and cold water and
here
we find a hot spring mixing with cold
stream water underneath her protective
motherly jaws and thus bringing their
legends to life the next morning I woke
up and I asked for tea I was handed a
mug a tea bag and well pointed towards
the river to my surprise the water was
clean and had a pleasant taste which is
a little weird for geothermal systems
what was amazing is that the locals had
always known about this place and that I
was by no means the first outsider to
see it it was just part of their
everyday life
they drink its water they take in its
vapor they cook with it clean with it
even make their medicines with it
I met the shaman and he seemed like an
extension of the river in this jungle he
asked for my intentions and listened
carefully then to my tremendous relief I
was freaking out to be honest with you a
smile began to snake across his face and
he just laughed I had received the
shamans blessing to study the river on
the condition that after I take the
water samples and analyze them in my lab
wherever I was in the world that I pour
the waters back into the ground so that
as the shaman said the waters could find
their way back home I've been back every
year since that first visit in 2011 and
the fieldwork has been exhilarating
demanding and at times dangerous one
story was even featured in the National
Geographic magazine I was trapped on a
small rock about the size of a sheet of
paper in sandals and board shorts in
between an 80 degree C River and a hot
spring that long looked like
is close to boiling and on top of that
it was Amazon rain forest pouring rain
couldn't see a thing
the temperature differential made it all
white it was a whiteout intense now
after years of work I'll soon be
submitting my geophysical and
geochemical studies for publication and
I'd like to share today with all of you
here on the Ted stage for the first time
some of these discoveries
well first off it's not a legend
surprise when I first started the
research the satellite imagery was too
low resolution to be meaningful there
were just no good maps thanks to the
support of the Google Earth team I now
have this not only that the indigenous
name of the river Shan I think Bershka
boiled with the heat of the Sun
indicating that I'm not the first to
wonder why the river boils and showing
that humanity has always sought to
explain the world around us so why does
the river boil it actually took me three
years to get that footage so fault fed
hot springs as we have hot blood running
through our veins and arteries so to the
earth has hot water running through its
cracks and faults where these arteries
come to the surface these earth arteries
will get geothermal manifestations
funerals hot springs and in our case the
boiling River what's truly incredible
though is the scale of this place next
time you cross the road think about this
the river flows wider than a two-lane
road along most of its path it flows hot
for six point to four kilometers truly
impressive
there are thermal pools larger than this
Ted stage and that waterfall that you
see there is six meters tall
and all with near boiling water we map
the temperatures along the river and
this was by far the most demanding part
of the fieldwork in the results or just
awesome sorry the geoscientist and me
coming up and it showed this amazing
trend you see the river starts off cold
then heats up cools back down heats up
cools back down heats up again and then
has this beautiful decay curve until it
smashes into this cold river now I
understand not all of you are geothermal
scientists sort of put it in the you
know more everyday terms
everyone loves coffee yes good your
regular cup of coffee 54 degrees C an
extra hot one well 60 so put in coffee
shop terms the boiling river plots like
this there you have your hot coffee here
you have your extra hot coffee and you
can see that there's a big point there
where the river is still hotter than
even the extra hot coffee and these are
average water temperatures we took these
in the dry season to ensure the purest
geothermal temperatures but there's a
magic number here that's not being shown
and that number is 47 degrees C because
that's where things start to hurt and I
know this from very personal experience
above that temperature you don't want to
get in that water you need to be careful
it can be deadly I've seen all sorts of
animals fall in and what's shocking to
me is the process is pretty much the
same so they fall in and the first thing
that go or the eyes eyes apparently cook
very quickly they turn this milky white
color the stream is carrying them
they're trying to swim out but their
meat is cooking on the bone because it's
so hot so they're losing power losing
power losing power until finally they
get to a point where hot water goes into
their mouths and they cook from the
inside out
a bit sadistic aren't we Jeannie leave
them marinating for a little longer
what's again amazing are these
temperatures they're similar to things
that I've seen on volcanoes all over the
world and even super volcanoes like
Yellowstone but here's the thing the
data is showing that the boiling River
exists independent of volcanism
it's neither magmatic or volcanic in
origin and again over 700 kilometers
away from the nearest volcanic center
how can a boiling River exist like this
I've asked geothermal experts and
volcanologist for years and I'm still
unable to find another non volcanic
geothermal system of this magnitude it's
unique it's special on a global scale
so still how does it work where do we
get this heat there's still more
research to be done to better constrain
the problem and better understand the
system but from what the data is telling
us now it looks to be the result of a
large hydrothermal system basically it
works like this so the deeper you go
into the earth the hotter it gets we
refer to this as the geothermal gradient
the waters could be coming as far away
as glaciers in the Andes then seeping
down deep into the earth and coming out
to form the boiling River after getting
heated up from that geothermal gradient
all due to this unique geologic setting
now we found that in and around the
river this is working with colleagues
from National Geographic dr. Spencer
wells and dr. John Eisen from UC Davis
we genetically sequenced the extrema
phial life-forms living in and around
the river and have found new life-forms
unique species live
in the boiling River but again despite
all of these studies all these
discoveries and the legends a question
remains what is the significance of the
boiling River what is the significance
of this stationary cloud that always
hovers over this patch of jungle and
what is the significance of a detail in
a childhood legend to the shaman in his
community it's a sacred site to me is a
geoscientist it's a unique geothermal
phenomenon but to the illegal loggers
and cattle farmers it's just another
resource to exploit and of the Peruvian
government it's just another stretch of
unprotected land ready for development
my goal is to ensure that whoever
controls this land understands the
boiling rivers uniqueness and
significance because that's the question
one of significance and the thing there
is we define significance it's us we
have that power we are the ones who draw
that line between the sacred and the
trivial and in this age where everything
seems mapped measured and studied in
this age of information I remind you all
the discoveries are not just made in the
black void of the unknown but in the
white noise of overwhelming data there
remains so much to explore we live in an
incredible world so go out be
be curious because we do live in a world
where shamans still sing to the spirits
of the jungle where rivers do boil and
where legends do come to life thank you
very much